hi everyone I'm here with the legendary
Steve Kaufman for those last few people
left in the world who don't know who
Steve Kaufman is uh he's a fantastic
language learner and
um Nepali gloss speaks a bunch of
languages and today we're going to talk
about something that is maybe not
controversial but it's interesting Steve
to talk about this because we agree in a
lot of things right but there are some
things right that we know we kind of
disagree with so let's let's address
those ones
exactly
um so let's talk about two I wanted to
to speak in particular about two things
so one is deliber practice and the other
one is error correction so in one recent
video that I watched you talk about the
plateau right this very common term to
say we we hit the plateau we're not
improving anymore and if I understood
correctly your view is well you don't
very much believe in a plateau because
you're constantly learning no matter
what we do we learn anyway right
um but we have the impression that we're
not learning but we are learning yeah
yeah yes that's that's absolutely true
uh having said that though don't you
believe that there are some places
within the language running curve or the
language learning path where it's more
difficult to move from let's say one
stage to the other and we should do
different things like Let me Give an
example someone who's been learning uh
say a language for three months they
listen they read uh they do a few things
but then you know they hit some sort of
place where they're not they get the
impression that they're not making
um you know progress anymore do you
think that we should just you know
listen and read and get a lot of input
and just do whatever we feel like it but
practice the language and then we're
gonna get there or do you think that we
might need to alternate some sort of
simple Practice What I Call simple
practice which is just exposure to the
language whether you speak it you listen
to it or you read it but also some sort
of deliberate practice we deliberately
sit down in order to hone our skills
like for example talking to a tutor
getting Corrections uh trying to
implement those corrections to improve
and uh or read and make sure that you
save words and you review words etc etc
so
I was curious to know your opinion about
that
um so uh I do talk to a tutor
once I have three or five thousand words
in the language
uh for a variety of reasons first of all
uh speaking is an important part of
language learning I'm not a big fan of
doing a lot of speaking when you have
very few words but once you have a
certain level in the language uh it's
good to practice speaking it's good
trying to retrieve from your much larger
passive vocabulary trying to retrieve
words that you can actually use uh
typically a good tutor uh asks me
questions gets me going I want to do
well for my tutor so it's motivating to
have a tutor uh I get a report from my
tutor a list of all the words that I
struggle to use I then and with audio I
import this into link I study it as a
lesson after six months I have a you
know six months times twice a week all
my sessions with my tutor that's
tremendous a record of how I progressed
in the language that's deliberate
learning
um I think when I'm you know listening
to something that I don't understand
very well of course I always study it on
my iPad add in link looking up words
increase and I'll sometimes go back and
review some of the words I'll review my
view on on sort of sent reviewing words
and phrases flash cards whatever you
want to call it is it should be easy it
should be a small number and it should
be right after you were engaged with the
content so like right now Korean which
has been a real struggle for me
um I'm doing a lot of sentence review so
I go in do it sentence by sentence uh in
each sentence I'll save two or three
words then we have a thing called
sentence review where I've got matching
pairs which is very uneasy form again
easy is key in flashcards don't scratch
your brain don't try to remember you go
try and match them no that's wrong you
find the one that's right fine and dandy
then you get to where you have to
reassemble the sense that's also a
deliberate study what you have to
balance is all of the deliberate study
you know reviewing the grammar even
that's time taken away away from massive
ingestion of more input where you're
learning new words so you have to have a
balance but it's certainly not just a
hundred percent one or a hundred the
other you've I I think it's 80 listening
and reading and saving words and 20 on
the nuts and bolts and and the details
and more deliberate study
okay interesting interesting uh answer
and I I'm I'm with you that you should
kind of balance input and also
deliberate study now in that vein I want
to also want to ask you this specific
question because I heard Stephen crash
and say this I I don't think you you set
the same or you believe the same but I
was really curious to know what you
think about this in one of the polygon
conferences I think it was in New York
he said something like along the lines
of you can learn a language through
input this is what he says normally and
then you can get massive input you're
going to learn the language and if you
understand the uh the messages now you
know that there's an Institute I think
it's called language growth I think it's
in Thailand where people first they
cannot speak the language in Thailand I
think this kind of backfires if you're
in country you should speak the language
but it's a different matter but
um according to this philosophy if you
are in class and you just you know
listen to the instructor you watch the
instructor instructor giving
instructions showing things Etc
um this is like comprehensible input
don't you think though that that is a
little bit slow so if tprs is also kind
of you know this this sort of of
teaching or of training or having people
learn languages
uh would you do that so there's two
things I wanted to ask you would you
just
um you know be in a class where you get
a lot of this kind of instructions where
you learn the language with an
instructor showing stuff and you know
you learn through the interaction as a
kid would and would you use say for
example graded readers from the very
beginning so graded readers are these
books that are kind of have simplified
language from the very beginning in a
language that is extremely distant from
yours so we're not talking about Spanish
we're not talking about French Italian
imagine trying to learn a language that
is completely different let's say
Turkish or let's say Arabic wouldn't it
be better to have a little bit also of
some grammar explanations or some help
some Aid where you can use your own
native language grammar notes or whatnot
translation in order to make strides at
the very beginning at the early stages
of language learning
okay uh first of all I'm against all
extreme Dogma so the idea that someone
is in Thailand and is not allowed to use
Thai is ridiculous I arrived in Japan
not knowing any not knowing any Japanese
I I spent so much time listening and
reading listening and reading but if I
walked into a store in fact I would
deliberately put myself in situations
where I had to use whatever limited
Japanese I have I mean you're there
you're surrounded by all these Delicious
Fruit and you're not allowed to eat them
it doesn't make any sense to me
whatsoever that's in so that's that
thing in Thailand where they forbid
people from speaking Thai that's
ridiculous
um I think that um
you know an overview of the grammar is
kind of useful but a lot of the basic
stuff uh we're gonna come across it
anyway if you say oh this language is
subject verb object or whatever once you
start reading it and and obviously
you've got to have access to a
dictionary that's another Point by the
way we can only learn things if we
relate them I mean it's faster if we
relate them to something we know and
that's why I always use a VI always use
a bilingual dictionary it doesn't have
to be back to English it can be to
another language that I know well but
I'm not going to deal with a monolingual
dictionary where every definition has a
bunch more words that I don't know I
want to relate it to something that I
know that for some overview of the
grammar can also be helpful we have to
be uh realistic that whatever we read
about the grammar we're not going to
remember it uh because it's again
describing something we don't know uh
it's like you know if you get
instructions on you know how do I get to
the grocery store and they say well you
go down the third intersection turn left
turn right turn left you forget that
explanation right away unless you've
already been there if you've already
walked that route then the explanation
will make sense and so similarly I very
much believe in you know perhaps an
overview of the grammar we like to hold
on to a little book you know
introductory book I always buy one but I
actually we have to get used to the
structure of the language through
massive input and we can then go back in
later on with more detailed explanations
of the grammar but up front we can't
take too much in the way of grammar
explanations because we don't know what
they're referring to we haven't
experienced it before so I think you
have to mix all of those things also the
tprs is based on the fact that you have
to learn in a classroom and fair enough
if you're teach if you're a teacher your
environment is the classroom So you
you're going to deal with things that
you can do in the classroom where you
know only five or ten out of the 25
students is even interested in learning
the language so you got to do things to
amuse them I'm not in the classroom when
I learn I don't want someone acting out
something and I'm having to try to guess
what they're saying I would rather
listen to something not understand half
of it read it look up words listen again
read again and gradually through
listening and reading acquire along you
know knowledge of the language and more
vocabulary I wouldn't put myself in a
situation where the teacher is acting
stuff out and we're having to guess what
they're saying but it's a different
environment you know if I had the class
I don't know what I'd do maybe I'd be
acting stuff out I don't know
fair enough
um I don't know going back to yeah going
back to the question before so would you
advise for someone
um to can can people actually learn a
language just through using just through
mere exposure to that language without
using any dictionary without using any
Aid just by listening and and uh and
reading a text or texts in that language
would you think that that is feasible
for languages not for languages that are
similar like Italian and Spanish but for
languages that are really distant
extremely difficult unnecessarily
difficult I mean we all know examples of
immigrants in Canada let's say who came
30 years ago and still can't speak the
language
uh so now they're not very motivated so
that's perhaps not if you are really
motivated but why would you do that uh
if I if I'm reading something and I see
a word I look it up Bingo that
explanation may not be 100 accurate for
that context but it starts the Journey
of understanding that word If instead I
got some explanation in the target
language which I also didn't understand
I'm nowhere so I I see no benefit in
doing that explain for example there are
aspects and this gets back to the
subject Corrections and grammar
explanations a lot of things we do
notice uh you know uh
especially if we're able to look up
words but a lot of things we don't
notice and so some explanation that you
know may not notice for example that say
uh I don't know in Russian the
unaccentuated vowel o becomes ah you
know or or the other way around or any
of these things that we don't we there's
a lot of stuff we don't notice so I I
say don't give us too much explanation
up front but some explanation some
reference back to your own language all
of these things are very helpful why
would you do without that I don't
understand
fully agreed okay I got two more
questions for you one is about it says
still in the in the realm of deliberate
practice and another one is about uh
error correction so let's say that
someone comes to you and asks you Steve
I already speak a language fluently I
can get my point across let's say I have
a B2 within the CFR scale right and they
want to get to Native like not
native-like pronunciation they want to
get to Native life skills so Express
themselves have a very solid grasp or a
native like rasp of their target
language and they have to move from B2
to say C1 or native like and they
already understand the language they
maybe understand they go to university
they understand movies what would you be
your advice uh in terms of stuff to do
that you know raises the bar so to speak
you know it's just massive involvement
with the language I mean and you do see
I'm ever forever impressed when I see
people on television might be
politicians
or others who speak with a you know
identifiable accent or maybe not so
identifiable but with an ever you know
an obvious accent and who Express
themselves so well in English Express
themselves better than many native
speakers use the language so well the
only way this is achieved is through
massive interaction with the language
massive listening and reading and
speaking you have to get with people and
you have to speak a lot and there is no
shortcut and so and we move very
gradually from B2 to C1
uh we're reading books in the language
we're watching movies in the language
we're spending you know evenings with
people in the language uh it's just
continuing along the way and if you have
a particular professional need obviously
seek out out you know content that's
relevant to your area of expertise so
that you're knowledgeable enough to
engage people on that subject of
expertise and all the time you're using
the languages listening and reading and
speaking to people you're constantly
improving so it's a gradual process you
can't force it you just have to continue
doing those things that will eventually
take you from B2 to C1
or yeah very good very good that's my
that's my feeling I agree I I think that
in order I always say
whoever comes and asks me how can I get
to Native like level I say you have to
live the same experience as the native
speakers went through when it comes to
learning when they learn their own
language so you have to live all those
experiences and it's not a matter like
we still tend to think that a language
is something that you learn I think a
language is is an entity that you get
familiar with with time more than
learning it's just the acquisition of
the language that happens through life
and we still see it as an item that we
have to master or we have to consciously
learn the reality is we're learning
please mostly we acquire a language
without even being conscious of that you
know sometimes at night absolutely do
something very intensive some words come
like I don't know Serbian they come at
night that that means that the brain at
night is processing the information that
it got exposed to during the day so
um it's it's great absolutely advice
excellent I agree with you 100 and we
also like if we're in a situation that
we haven't experienced before
uh because the brain operates on helping
us cope with situations in life so that
when we are in that situation once we're
not really able to cope but the second
time the third time we cope better and I
mean I've mentioned the example of
buying a train ticket in a station in St
Petersburg and I I hadn't been in that
situation before I spoke Russian fairly
well I couldn't understand what the lady
was saying like you have to put yourself
in all these different situations so
that then you come to that same
situation again and then you'll
understand what people are saying uh so
I agree with you we get used to
operating living in that language by
putting ourselves in so many different
situations in the language
absolutely fabulous that's it not just
not just becoming familiar getting
familiar with the language but the
situations right you you said it you had
it I had a very similar thing with a
very in Hungarian they say morsos to say
a grumpy this grumpy kind of communist
you know those grumpy girls and these
books oh yes you know you know the time
so you had it like in hungry so she was
looking at me like what are you gonna
ask me You Foreigner and I just asked
her a question and she blah blah blah I
couldn't understand it and people are
merciless in the sense that people
they're not teachers they don't expect
you know you cannot expect people to
just sit down and say oh can you repeat
again they're just like boom like they
go about their business every day so I
was just like oh my goodness but that
ring like I that helped me because they
went through that and and every time
that I learned a language this might
sound weird coming from a polyglot or an
experienced language learner every
single time I learn a foreign language I
always have my heart beating or it's
only there's always a little bit of
anxiety sure because we're not used to
living these situations in another
language it's always like reliving your
life again and having to go through
these like asking for a ticket or going
to school for the first time in a
different language
um you know meeting the parents so it's
it's it's uh on the one side it can be a
little bit it can bring about a little
bit of anxiety but it's an exhilarating
experience because you're living you
have to live these experiences again I
always say that you know fluency is not
just about the amount of words you know
or the amount of sentences it's also the
com it's a level of confidence you have
it you build it only through living life
living exceptions
anyway absolutely thank you thank you
for that great answer and let's talk
about the last thing of of the interview
right yeah that's air correction now I
know your opinion well because I watch
all your videos practically uh and uh it
it correct me if I'm wrong I from what I
understood you think I notice we talked
about this with Stephen crashen that
getting corrected is really not that
useful because it flies over your head
and you're gonna forget about that and
eventually you realize you you kind of
notice your mistakes and you correct
them is that is that correct did I
understood correctly
uh yeah with with the caveat that there
are things that you will never notice
until they're corrected for you but the
bulk of the corrections you won't
remember uh it won't improve you I've
had the experience when I was a tutor I
corrected this German guy he kept on
making the same mistake I kept on
correcting him he kept on making the
same mistake uh people say you well
mothers correct their children that's
not true as you know children don't
learn from their parents or otherwise
children of immigrants would never learn
to speak with native-like accents so
most of the Improvement is if you're
interested you're noticing how people
are using the language you're gradually
acquiring better language habits uh when
I have a tutor online I mean they send
me a report of our discussion I notice
some of the corrections there but I make
the same mistake next week next week
next week like it's not bad but I think
the students should be should not depend
on someone else correcting them and if
I'm having an interesting conversation
with us with someone where we have
meaningful things that we're exchanging
and then they start correcting my
language that's almost discouraging
so it's certainly unsolicited error
correction I'm very much against I don't
think we should rely on error correction
but it's not a bad thing I just don't
think it's that important as a part of
our language learning Journey
okay I'm with you I although I have to
say that in my in my personal case
um you know air correction has been
quite useful I agree with you that most
of the time you know some some things we
can notice some others fly over our head
like eludes us so to speak and someone
has to point that out an example with
English
I remember I remember back in the day
was 20 years ago when I was just hanging
out with an American friend and I said
sir quit and he said no it's not circuit
it's circuit and uh I used to say
motivation instead of motivation and I
believe that air correction is useful
when it's it you expect it so it's if it
comes unsolicited unsolicited is really
bad it backfires each and right I
believe that when you have a higher
level in the language you tend to absorb
that feedback way better this has been
my case I don't know about yours
absolutely if I'm a beginner if I'm a
beginner
um someone correct me is just gotta turn
me off and it's a disaster but when I'm
at my like let's say a B2 Corrections
they stick because I've built this this
big connection like this big networking
in my head and when someone points
something out it's really I can absorb
it easily so I believe the air
correction depends also on the phase of
your language learning path and in my
case it's been extremely useful and I
really enjoy it when I ask for it so I
sit down with a friend and say please
correct me whenever I make a mistake and
I have a higher level but if I'm at a
beginner stages that's a complete
disaster just backfires really bad so
this has been my opinion I don't know
what you think about this I think I
agree 100 I think that's one of the best
explanations I've heard I hadn't heard
that before uh imagine a jigsaw puzzle
and you're just getting started and you
timidly put out a few pieces and someone
says no no that's wrong you know whereas
when you have only a few pieces left
and someone gives you you know well try
that piece that's helpful and so when we
have more of the pieces already in place
and we're anxious to become better
and we have the confidence that we
actually really know the language quite
well then correction is actually quite
welcome and more likely to help us and
as you said at the very beginning the
person is just trying to blurt out the
language and they all they want is
encouragement and at that level the
correction is a bad thing I think that
you've hit the nail on the head there
thank you wonderful wonderful answer
from your side as well so we agree uh on
that
um and I think with that we've we've
tackled these two things
one day maybe maybe next year we can get
back to you remember what we did a lot I
think it's been 10 years time flies we
had this multiple language or
multilingual image oh yeah it was back
in the day maybe we could do it in 2024.
I'd love it I'd love to sure yeah
anytime or another get together like
Bratislava which is already you know a
few years in the past I will be here
today look I'm very yeah I am very
disappointed I thought we were going to
be able to disagree on stuff
and here we disagree we agree on
everything how can that be yeah I I
wanted to try to lock horns with you and
try to you know disagree with something
but at the end of the day we tend to
agree on pretty much everything so I I
don't know why right but it's a good
sign maybe I think it's a good sign
maybe we're both wrong maybe we're both
wrong maybe we're both wrong but we're
on the same side thank you Steve so much
for uh okay thank you and uh I will I
will talk to you soon
okay thank you bye-bye ciao bye